[Musique]
c'est le point culminant du printemps
étudiants 2000 manifestants sont réunis
à victoriaville
pendant le congrès du parti libéral la
sphère va mal finir
bilan officiel trois blessés graves qui
perdu six dents sur le coup j'avais une
fracture à la mâchoire va de deux
endroits on a même craint pour la vie
d'alexandre allard j'ai malheureusement
fait cette hausse ne s'est pas fait pour
être commencer à faire c'est s'impose
pose non plus d'être un tueur
normalement donc quand je vois les yeux
à la télé géants maintenant on ça
recommence je peux pour quoi que
j'utilisais balles de plastique
le soir même la sûreté du québec affirme
déjà ne pas être responsable oui
effectivement
la sûreté du québec a utilisé quelques
armes d'impact des balles de caoutchouc
mieux des manifestants qui ont été
blessés à 20 on commence à utiliser ces
armes d'impact que s'est il réellement
passé le 4 me la sûreté du québec était
de mise en danger la sécurité des
manifestants avec des armes
potentiellement fatale
dominique la liberté n'est pas genre de
femme qui sait sabbath et l'a mis des
mois à reprendre ses activités après
avoir été blessé à victoriaville
êtes vous une tendresse garde non j'aime
observer ce qui se passe puis donner mon
appui mais je peux la plus brillante
vous participez de quelle façon manif en
suivant le troupeau dominique la liberté
arrive de québec en autobus avec ses
amis
en peu de temps le périmètre de sécurité
est renversé et c'est l'escaladé
à partir du moment où on lance des
roches à des policiers on commet un acte
criminel
presqu'immédiatement la manifestation
est déclaré illégal
les héritages chimiques sont utilisés
pour disperser la foule
quand ils ont lancé juste lancé des gaz
mais ça m'a surpris je n'avais jamais
vécu ce petit commencer même style on s
attaque pas seulement le tout leur sens
les effets donc je sais j'ai ça me
surprit l'uci si ce serait juste parce
que je leur raconte à tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
dominique la liberté est loin de la
ligne de front
nous ne peut plus d'un coin éloigné
offrant la gorge d'entrée par précaution
elle traverse la rue il contourne un
bâtiment pour se rendre au milieu d'un
terrain vague où elle se croit à l'abri
mais la foule est repoussé dans la même
direction
tout à coup dominique la liberté
s'écroule atteinte par un projectile en
plein visage
parmi les gens qui se portent à son
secours se trouvent à bab el hamdi il
porte le dossard orange
il nous a confirmé avoir vu à ses pieds
ce projectile vert qui pourrait avoir
frappé la jeune femme
le arwen est une arme anti-émeute qui
fait partie de l'arsenal de la sûreté du
québec
elle utilise les projectiles ar1 qu'on
appelle des bâtons cinétique balles de
plastique ou balles de caoutchouc
mais peut-être qu'un arbre de vie
simple terminologie deal fabricant
l'essentiel à retenir est temps que les
projectiles sont faits de polymère s 80
grammes et voyagent à la vitesse de 74
mètres à la seconde
les projections des pets vont beaucoup
plus vite qu'une balle de baseball et il
arrive qu'ils tuent les premières
générations de balles de plastique et de
caoutchouc ont fait 10 morts en irlande
du nord après le décès du petit steven
l'économie le parlement européen et les
nations unies ont recommandé de ne plus
utiliser ces projectiles contre des
manifestants l'armée britannique a
plutôt choisi de développer une arme
améliorer le arwen une compagnie
ontarienne en a fait l'acquisition en
2001 et le vend partout dans le monde
dominique la liberté est persuadé
d'avoir été blessé par un de ces
projectiles à victoriaville
pourquoi l'hypothèse que les policiers
semblent avancer que ça puisse être une
drillet qu'une ruche où peu importe pour
vous semble incohérent
parce que j'étais éloigné ça je vois pas
comment j'aurais pu vraiment dans le
sens où j'étais ça ça serait les
policiers auraient lancé des briques ou
quoi fini ce nom elle est donc surprise
quelques jours plus tard quand la sûreté
du québec en conférence de presse
écarte la possibilité qu'elle puisse
avoir été atteinte par un projectile
cette personne nous déclarera plus tard
qu'elle était à environ 2 ou 300 mètres
des policiers lorsque ça s'est produit
et je vous rappelle que la portée
maximale d'un projectile d'impact
utilisait la sûreté du québec c'est 100
m
nous sommes allés vérifier sur place les
estimations de dominique la liberté elle
dit se trouver à peu près ici selon nos
mesures elles seraient bien à
l'intérieur d'un rayon de 100 mètres de
la ligne des policiers est donc à portée
de leurs projectiles
[Applaudissements]
avant d'être blessé alexandre allard est
assez proche du coeur de la
manifestation
il est facilement reconnaissable dans la
foule avec son drôle de chapeau à
l'effigié du drapeau du québec 10 où
certains ne le cache pas je devrais en
près de l'action
mais en fait c'était seulement pour voir
sud plus précis je m'attendais pas à ce
que quelque chose l'a tiré parce que
c'est ça j'ai jamais lu fidèles d'action
qui mériteraient seul en effet grâce à
son chapeau nous l'avons repérée à
plusieurs reprises dans nos images
jamais une pause de gestes menaçants par
contre juste avant d'être atteint il est
derrière un groupe de gens qui résistent
aux policiers
l'utilisation de ce type d'armes est
exclusivement à l'égard de gens
dangereux qui représente une menace à
l'égard des policiers ou de citoyens
alexandre allard était peut-être au
mauvais endroit
la sûreté du québec croit plutôt qu'il a
été blessé par d'autres manifestants
parce que si j'étais atteint mon côté
gauche voit les policiers qui précède un
autre gros chat qu'on marche et puis de
cette façon lounge jamais vu le
projectile j'ai juste vu un ex recevoir
un impact tombe à terre chose certaine
l'impact du projectile est considérable
mais en fait c'était très ciblé le
commun comme impact parce que tout cas
j'étais atteint ça s'est déchiré mon
l'homme c'est quand même de façon
circulaire quand même en plus 6 a
atteint le rocher le noceur en paroles
en aucun temps nos policiers n'ont visé
ou non tirées en direction des parties
vitales ou de la tête de quelques
individus que ce soit
en formation on apprend aux policiers à
éviter certaines parties du corps mais
plusieurs rapports font état du manque
de précision des armes à distance et des
risques accrus dans une foule en
mouvement justement il faisait quelque
chose mais patatras c'est ça juste à
temps et moins à rien mais le principal
argument de la sûreté du québec
c'est l'heure à laquelle dominique la
liberté et alexandre allard ont été
touchés peu avant 19 heures qu'on peut
affirmer c'est que il ya deux personnes
qui sont déjà blessés
à ce moment là on n'a pas encore
commencé à diffuser nos armes d'impact
ok il ya déjà des ambiances et sur place
les rapports ambulanciers contredisent
la version policière
les blessés n'ont pas été prise en
charge avant 19 heures puisque c'est
l'heure précise où la première ambulance
a été appelée suivi de la douzième à
19h04 pourtant le soir même le lendemain
et à nouveau six jours plus tard la
sûreté du québec et 6,7 à 19 heures
effectivement
que l'ordre fut donnée de pouvoir
utiliser les armes d'impact aux
policiers qui étaient sur le terrain
parce que il doit y avoir un ordre nos
images racontent leur propre histoire et
ce n'est pas la même il faut savoir qu'à
victoriaville la sûreté du québec
utilisent deux armes d'aspe similaires
le fusil fédéral ne lance que
déshéritant chimiques
c'est une arme à un coût qui produit un
grand nuage de gaz le à roanne se
distingue par son chargeur circulaire
qui peut tirer cinq projectiles
seulement vingt policiers de la sûreté
sont autorisés à utiliser cette arme de
ses vins la la journée de l'émeute dans
9 6 qui était affecté à cette opération
de ces six là il y en a cinq qui ont
utilisé larmes d'impact au moins deux de
ces tireurs sont déployés sur la ligne
face aux étudiants entre 18h45 et 19
heures le 2 s'avance devrait attirer
puis se retire
apparemment sans déclencher son arme est
il possible que dirais tu eu lieu avant
l'ordre donné à 19h
[Musique]
le sommet des amériques à québec en 2001
donnent lieu à d'intenses confrontation
le 21 avril vers 15h la foulée dispersé
avec des irritants chimique avec la
ferrière qui manifestent pour la
première fois de sa vie trouve la
réaction des policiers exagéré et
membres est en mouvement tout le temps
le puis ils m'ont à pogny en co2 ou
stock je mets sur déplier faire un polar
à navailles j'en ai reçu une deuxième
commande engorge le voici dans une des
rares entrevues accordées à l'époque
eric laferrière a eu de la chance de
survivre
le projectile tiré de harwanne par un
policier de québec a causé une fracture
multiple du larynx
quand je me revois les yeux à l'hôpital
la première fois le matin dz j'en
parlerai plus vous avez eu de nombreuses
raisons cesse eric laferrière a gardé
d'importantes séquelles la cour
supérieure a toutefois rejeté sa
poursuite en dommages contre la ville de
québec
faute de pouvoir identifier le policier
impliqué nous ne trouvait que
cette utilisation de cette forme d'art
menacées tête atteindra justifie qu
maître rené milette était parmi les cinq
observateurs nommé par le ministre de la
sécurité publique pour s'assurer du
respect des droits fondamentaux des
manifestants ils ont conclu que l' usage
des balles de plastique est une
violation du droit à la sécurité dans
une manifestation
c'est tellement dangereux tellement
tellement dangereux nous aussi dit quand
parce que j'en ai eus on les voyait
parts à écouter ça arrive dans un oeil
c'est sûr sacré venait ça peut casser la
dentition ça peut casser des côtes
c'est déjà arrivé le à roanne a fait un
mort à montréal en 1995 et tout a été
captée par une de nos caméras
certaines de ces images pourraient
déranger les policiers tentent de
défoncer la porte de salvatore ferraro
un schizophrène en crise barricadé chez
lui
affolée l'homme menace les policiers qui
ripostent en tirant trois projectiles
quelques minutes plus tard les policiers
trouvent fait rare aux morts l'impact a
causé une fracture des côtes qui a
perforé le coeur c'est l'âme la
meilleure à utiliser dans cette occasion
là c'est ce que ça peut causer un des
serpents des plats
le coroner est plus nuancé il note qu'à
3 m le policier n'a pas respecté la
distance recommandée par le fabricant et
rappelle que l' usage des balles de
plastique est controversée dans le cadre
du contrôle de foule
[Musique]
s'il y a un moment à victoriaville où la
police peut se défendre d'avoir recours
à la force
c'est celui ci quand un policier sans
protection est agressé pendant qu'il
tente une arrestation c'est là que la
majorité des balles de plastique sont
tirés ainsi la dans l'extrémité droite
il ya le politique va apparaître un
moment donné ne quitte c'est une
première balle premier coup deuxième
coup pilotto se dégage suis une chanson
russell les mêmes images vues d'un autre
angle on voit les silhouettes de maxence
valade qui tente péniblement de se
relever
il est sûr d'avoir été atteint par un
tir des policiers au moment où il
s'approchait ça s'est rendu juste au
tinel puisqu'on m'a causé un traumatisme
crânien puis ça fera qu'à son visage qui
ont donné la part de monnaie par la
suite la sûreté du québec est allé
jusqu'à saisir le dossier médical de
maxence balade au motif qu'il aurait
possiblement été victime d'une agression
armée que le soumettre à un pathologiste
et ce pathologiste judiciaire nous dit
concernant la personne qui étaient
blessés entre autres à l'oeil que la
blessure la grandeur de la blessure
accueilli aurait fallu quelque chose de
plus gros que pour causé le dommage qui
est la plus gros qu'un bâton cinétique
nexans balade n'a jamais été examinée
par cet expert par contre les médecins
qui m'ont opéré n'ont pas spécifié le
fait que ça ne pouvait pas être un bâton
ce n'est celles qui meurent et à la paix
donc à leur sens il n'excluait pas cette
possibilité là
rappelez vous qu'on utilise le guen dans
le but de neutraliser quelqu'un jamais
pour le tuer ou le blesser gravement
c'est comme un avertissement une petite
tape sur l'épaule du fabricant le
policier doit éviter de viser la tête et
ne pas tirer à moins de 20 mètres de la
licence entre le policier qui a tiré et
moins que d'environ 10 mètres donc
s'envoler c'est une utilisation abusive
et de la honte quel policier d'être en
ce moment le sénat le coroner avait noté
le même problème ou décès de monsieur
ferraro le juge avait fait le même
constat dans le cas d'eric laferrière au
sommet des amériques
la sûreté du québec affirme pourtant que
ces policiers ont respecté les règles à
victoriaville
ils l'ont fait avec discipline ils l'ont
fait avec rigueur et en fonction des
lois et règlements nous avons demandé à
la sûreté de nous fournir l'ensemble de
ces règles pour les armes d'impact nous
n'avons pas encore eu de réponse
quant au ministère de la sécurité
publique
il nous dit ne pas détenir de documents
sur ces sujets mais qu'ils élaborent
seulement maintenant une pratique
policière sur les armes intermédiaires
au delà des règles la police martèle
qu'elle ne peut être responsable des
deux premiers blessés pour une simple
raison et je le répète l'autorisation de
tuer les armes n'est pas cette arrivée à
19 heures revenons à nos images
nous avons deux caméras dont l'horloge
interne coïncide à une seconde près dé
18h35 avant que la manifestation soit
déclaré illégales les à roanne sont
déployés sur le terrain 18h55 le
policier menace de tirer mais semble se
raviser 18h55 46 secondes
alexandre allard se repère dans la foule
son avance moins on ne tourne comme
celui ci donc c'est combien de temps à
peu près 20 bonjour aux gens ne seront
que six à trente secondes et 20 secondes
12 secondes plus tard noté le policier
qui s'avance au fond il tire un léger
nuage entoure le projectile au même
moment sur ces images d'un témoin prise
en sens inverse
on aperçoit aussi un policier qui vise
les manifestants tout fait après
alexandre allard est tout seul le crâne
fracassé
jusqu'à un sommet politique tant de ses
fils ou ma fille j'ai jamais eu
conscience qu'il y aller' pour avoir ces
gens de répression nous sommes avec eux
des fusils qui fait qu'il est dommage
comme ça non plus - brad avoir la
victime j'ai vu une belle place et on
n'a pas une victime comme seul je devais
trouver des petites sortes de raisons
mais moi je parle tu as raison la plus
logique c'est la balle de place et
guillaume aspirent au mas et un manteau
jaune est pompier volontaire est formé
comme premiers répondants
alexandre allard a été déplacée quatre
fois au risque d'aggraver ses blessures
parce que les policiers continuaient de
repousser la foule vers lui dans ces
meurtres en charge et un peu
[Applaudissements]
on m'a pris la décision de bouger la
victime parce que le sait tout ça
semblait trop acheter
[Musique]
alexandre allard est devenu presque
sourd d'une oreille je vois pas
l'intérêt d'avoir une âme tu peux tuer
des gens dans l'écho est ce que personne
mieux de mourir non sans talent c'est
pour st pons champ de bataille s'était
pas je peux un criminel dont j'avais pas
de rejeter par mais j'avais absolument
rien sur moi faites y avait aucune
raison de jeu ne menaçait pas la vie de
ce pays d'ici là contrairement à eux qui
menaçait ma vie qui ont des hommes qui
tirent en deçà de 20 mètres ce qui peut
être fatale pour une personne dominique
la liberté à 3 ans de traitement et de
chirurgie de vente elle pourquoi pour
qu'on les suit encore plus hafsi autant
de celle ci et des dommages collatéraux
c'est fou puis ont placé des rapports
qui ont fait jamais fait un pressing
après deux sommets des amériques le
rapport des observateurs condamnant les
armes des pactes dans le contrôle de
foule a eu peu d'écho on nous a jamais à
pire nous jamais consulté pour quoi que
ce soit ni de la part du ministère
la part des cas pas ici qu'on travaille
très fort pour justement avoir des
réponses aux questions qui sont posées
que son qu'on se pose nous mène
d'ailleurs qu'on se pose nouman
s'il s'avère que la police a causé des
blessures graves et permanentes les
victimes estiment être en droit de le
savoir
le commissaire à la déontologie
policière se penche en ce moment sur les
événements la sûreté du québec dit ne
pas avoir complété sa propre enquête et
que ses conclusions ne seront pas
publiques
[Musique]